so now Monica why haven't already better
here two brothers and sisters and dear
friends welcome to another episode of
the house short and shallow
of course I've got very esteemed guests
here myself obviously Andrew got some
roses you just call me to sit down about
the wood and what BOSU can nail a best
inshaallah could be real each other
yeah my shoes don't fit on the comment
section guys also just want to say that
a big shots are a big thank to one of
our main sponsors for our marriage
documentary inshaallah which is coming I
know that was lost hope but inshallah
I'm perfecting it who's making it happen
the Muslim box call company from the
mistaken they do amazing gifts check
them out which all I want to put a link
there do check them out they're actually
helping me to get the process running
fast insurance for me all a blessing
there one of our sponsors as well as
human relief foundation etc anyway so
basically today we're gonna be reacting
to a comment about a one-night stand
okay so this is something that I saw and
personally I felt of it as a man like I
felt a bit like not just uncomfortable
but her I felt like her yeah
so one word is I want to show it to you
guys yeah you guys ready so this is not
video that would be acid reacting to a
coming here or somebody yeah on the
screen yeah
so this is some guy called trap mentions
name I'm gonna put bear out yeah so he
goes so I had sex with this girl and
after we got done she closed her eyes
started crying I asked I asked her
what's wrong she said you're gonna leave
me after this and then he goes bro that
whoever almost made me cry because she
was right yeah so I don't know now I
don't know if he the last comment he
means in a sarcastic way or he actually
means that you know actually that is
what I'm gonna do here so now I don't
know how you guys feel about this but me
personally I felt very distraught yeah
the reason being is like right this guy
is given a reality so if he's not being
sarcastic he's basically saying yeah
that's that's that's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go so I'm gonna assume it's
not south as opposed because his face
there
but the reason I felt like a bit you
know disgusted and it really affected me
is because it's just sad you know
because the fingers if you look at
society today's it's so much up yeah you
know somebody might come and say to me
you know what she's a female she's a
riot you know she has a right to do this
you know she feels like that no they
don't I don't think it's in within a
female's nature I'll be honest I don't
think within a female's nature should
just be messed around you know just be
messed around there you know they might
act stronger me like oh no you know I'm
an independent woman I choose who I want
to sleep with et cetera but the fact
that like this is going on this is a
reality that within women's natures they
need security today I'm trying to say so
I don't know personally I feel really
really upset my like like you know it's
something might say look you know like
come on what's wrong with you - I think
woman no it's sad the fact that she
feels like you're gonna leave me as well
it shows that she's this happened to her
before you know even - mentioned yeah
they both of them acknowledged yeah she
acknowledges prior to doing it yeah and
after the act yeah that he's gonna leave
her and he see that's why I like in new
people on the show that that's quite
profound exactly so you're telling me
knowing knowing knowing the reality
before it's happened and they still next
it's still accepted it so she's she
knows didn't mention anything didn't
speak it was after that she sighed
crying yeah so prior to the ice they
knew was gonna happen she knew that
after the act he's gonna leave me so
what does that what does that really say
because the fingers if somebody knows
it's gonna happen they still doing it
are they a victim adays Wow say is
acceptance no reality so her crying is
shows that obviously she doesn't want
him to leave her she's kind of did some
emotion emotion attention yeah there's
some attachment was there whether it be
towards her dignity
or whether it is something going on oh
yeah so after that she's accepted the
fact that he's going to leave her so and
her crying shows that she's emotionally
responding to it she dislikes him so I
would say it shows acceptance because
she doesn't do anything about it yeah
she just allows it to happen to her so
what lucky me for two reasons
that could be either it's just a fake
person for example she just likes doing
it just cries after or which I believe
the other the the latter is that this
she's trapped in a system yeah and the
system is like this and she has no
choice but to do it now you might come
and say no comment she'd you get it no
one forced about what I'm seeing is that
you need to understand just because you
haven't got a gun to your head does it
mean you're not forced you know because
if the system is letting the people down
where she's thinking okay look I want to
get married I don't to be in the show I
wouldn't have one man that I can love
and have children with etc but the
system that we live in today men I mean
bout them they don't want that they want
to get it so I'm falling victim to the
system yeah so this is what I see I see
like somebody crying out because it's
like somebody who's sinning and then
they cry because they hate the sin but
they doing it because maybe they fall
into their desires or whatever it may be
but it's like it reminds me of the man
with the companion of the person where
he was drinking alcohol yeah and the
companies would you yeah now imagine the
Prophet peace be upon him is a messenger
Allah is there and you're doing
something you know in front of him and
the companies would wanna whip him yet
and they would curse my 1.1 companions
start cursing him out you know me I'll
not do this and I stopped him and I said
don't say that to me all I know he loves
online his messenger yeah so that deep
inside yeah you know yeah exactly
exactly so yeah man it just seems that
somebody who's doing it out of I don't
know what you would you feel might not
know bracing when I read the compound
when I read the tweet it's actually
quite shocking cuz I mean look at the
start it is so I had sex with yeah this
girl this girl very casual it's very so
it really shows you where our society is
how coach has developed
yeah where you know you would kiss and
tell to like a friend hmm
and then maybe that friend would tell
another friend yeah but it would kind of
remain you circle now you don't know who
this guy is
right would you were a be free
technology were able to have a window
into someone's life and how they live
their life so what shocks me actually is
the way says
very casually well so the other day I
was walking that's that's how he starts
and he says not sound normalizes because
yes it has normalized right and then he
goes on and says we got done so she
closed her eyes so and then so from one
like this casual thing that he was doing
the other day it gets very intense
because now he's confronted with her
most emotions and then strange enough
that touches him to me if you were to
ask me do you think he's done at once no
he seems to someone he's been doing it
and I feel like this time was the time
that really hate him something he and it
was the honesty of this of this girl
because like he was saying early on a
lot of these girls I know for the fact
man is what a lot of manliest of humans
who are involved in that type of
lifestyle tend to pretend that they're
fine and they don't need anyone and they
move on after whatever happens but the
reality is that you know you bond like
these at night you bond energies you
know that act I believe really in that
in this stuff when you you have you an
active of intercourse you are exchanging
energies we're supposed to be this is
supposed to be positive yeah it's
positive it's sacred right we know of
the hadith where says with the Sahaba
said to the Prophet how system do we get
punished now do we get rewards sleeping
follows and in the process said you get
punishment for sins he said the way the
way you get sin or committing zina is
the way you get reward for now yes doing
it in a halal way yeah so the act of
intercourse in Halawa is a sacred it's
very sacred and it's something that is
supposed to be between husband and wife
yeah now we live in a time we've become
like drinking water to boniest is active
in history it's always been the case
even it if you follow love films from
recent days every time someone's exposed
themselves to someone else they've lost
a part of themselves yeah so they say
for example the best relationship will
be the
one with your first relationship if you
have several relationships you now for
example protect yourself you don't trust
Taurus and you don't correct expose
yourself to frustration
most world comes with a lot of madnesses
now one of the things that come just
gonna bring it in here is act like
marriage documentary which is the home
fundamental thing behind it and the
reason why it's a bit late is because
I'm trying to perfect it in a way where
the whole point behind it is to avoid
the sinner yes my journey of this is
what I went through to avoid zina yeah
the ups and downs and the madness and
all that crazy stuff that you watch
inshallah is this is the struggle
because it's so destructive zina is so
destructive to the so if I'm sayin oh
yeah sorry like sex outside of marriage
yeah it's so destructive and if I'm not
mistaken saladin are you being said if
you wanna destroy a nation make a
promise promise create promiscuous stuff
like within the community make it happen
like bases that will rule the
communities so the thing is that's why
it's really really important you know
that just shows you how destructive it
is man it just it just really shows that
the shots with and it's it's it's it's
really sad lost you both now just is the
Amish I'm assuming this person is known
I don't even know it seems like a random
crime yeah so if the issue is in the
females position yeah even the tweet see
this is why it's not protection protects
a woman in my news because even the
tweet yeah now for example much is a
selfie that she's now bypassed she's
situation now is exposed yes even if no
one knows who is
she's now a situation again yeah and if
it's posted again yes she's remembering
again phone so even in Islamic
perspective benefical protection even in
this aspect she's being protected mmm
because even though he's not mentioned
anything but like he said no it's become
is our video people who know him and
know her might know yeah it might not a
situation she might spoken to her friend
about me yeah and interceder okay her
friend found out free elsewhere PC also
what this shows me at is three it really
shows me where we going as as humans and
he told you using our human and humanity
because I mean this is this was given
birth by the sexual revolution of the
60s and 70s where where females and in
particular because you know females have
always been kept in like this cage
apparently not that from different
aspects I agree but from a sexual
perspective this is what has happened 50
years after after this revolution you
know I can sleep with whoever I want I
can do whatever I want with my sexuality
but you see fast food that you talk 2018
we have humans crying after an act where
you should actually feel more relaxed
yeah you should feel loved and there's a
lot of people he feels the opposite and
that's that's that's the bath of of
being free and do whatever you already
has consequences you see for the young
people that I think and everything is a
you know excitement yeah everything is
play yeah everything is joy and whether
is a young boy with his young girl this
is the example for the young female she
is supposed to be doing something I
supposed to be a desire is supposed to
be exciting is supposed to be fun
you know other girls are directing being
directed towards that she is now come
after the act and she's crying yeah now
when someone's crying out of you know
feeling bad normally is a dire situation
yeah it's not something that's normal
you don't get shot you know you're
teaching a new crowd and this works in
different ways MA now there's this is
there is situations where there's girls
there's sisters who are good good
sisters good people but because and you
know sometimes I blame a lot of time the
brothers you know I'm good sometimes say
to me why because I believe you know
like no no I blame the brothers because
the you know they give false hopes and
stuff like that but at the end of the
day it's
sisters in control like in a way where
it's just a few do not allow it's not
gonna happen
yeah unless is rape is it the situation
is understand that you're in control now
you might come as a manipulator yes okay
but you're still in control to say no I
feel Allah and that's the reason why
those ones are legislated that you're
worried your father's in in that place
as your protector
why because a man knows a man everything
that a line is messenger said believe me
the prophets of Salim doesn't talk or
utter but there is wisdom behind it
there is nothing even today when we had
food here
usually we could hear what this is on
food I would my own future today we went
unsaid you know what I'm gonna eat I
order some stuff we were shared together
on yeah broth that plate was clean yeah
and the poster of Salim said yeah and
the first items it was enough for one is
enough for two yeah and you live it so
it's a Sunnah and the process of selling
whatever he says he says it's one reason
like the man who came in at all but the
promise of Allah makes in a permissible
for me yeah and the frost I said I'm
obviously if it was you get a few
brothers you studied the religion here
they would have done but Buffy will
probably beat the crap out the guy yeah
but look I'd taken by the process and
reason with him you know some of the
comments what we're gonna beam up
yeah and he's asking the private message
or a lot to make something on this
island he said would you like that for
your sister he made him realize and this
guy if you're watching this huge I don't
know everything for watch it but would
you like that food system ajan someone
doing that to your sister
yeah so the apt is wrong we're not
saying don't do it cuz it's gonna be
done to assist at the act from the
get-go is wrong here
so I'm gonna I'm gonna wrap up his any
loss well you guys wanna say I think I
think this is a very interesting topic
and also what is very interesting is
that is showing you humans yeah this
this is what happens when for 450 years
you have a diesel car and you put petrol
into him yeah eventually the engine will
crack yes and that's exactly what's
happening she is a human she's acting
the way human would act yes if you're
doing something that humans are supposed
to do in a certain way yeah how are you
doing it the wrong way that's that's
that's a reaction everyone and also
another thing I just wanted to correct
you early on you said
females feel in a certain way man's man
equally in in in a certain way they feel
vulnerable if a man gets rejected by a
girl he likes or he knows that the girls
playing him yeah man are very hurt by
that to not of course of course but I
don't fit do you think the same level
where it's like a woman is actually
being used for a certain tackle for
medicine like sometimes pleasure the
coaches the coaches will be in nowadays
I mean I don't want any reference in me
came out with a type of music for men to
like he has songs where he talks about
how people played him it didn't exist
before but now in 2018 you have that so
it's in wow what one she is very
important that people need to understand
that this act here has been wrapped
about or has been sung about you know
like the decide chick thing a few years
ago it was very big sidechick they were
been accepted oh I'm I'm number two I'm
number I'm number two like I'm I'm
decide chick another view on that is but
that so it's things that are in culture
and their sung by artists they're shown
and this reality shows love and hip-hop
Zoey normalizes things and then you see
people talking about it like it's
nothing you see again this is this is
this whole court you've got one minute
this whole tweet I mean how it shows
what it shows is if you just follow
complete your desires mm-hmm and you
don't think and you don't follow your
brain then the act of following your
desires is gonna lead to self-harm yeah
just by doing the desires of this now if
you fulfill your desire but you start
thinking of how you think okay is this
person right for me is this person is he
gonna leave me okay that if you don't
leave me I don't need him is this
possible stay with me can I have kids
with you yeah and you do the ice long
term it's not a self development so it's
not like a fix yeah of course of course
you've become a better person when you
do the right things when you know it's
not doesn't stop your desires yeah yeah
it's not to stop your desire no it's to
truffaut different for them in the right
way control them feel for them in the
right way so what is the moral of the
story the moral of the story is in the
Quran you know what our boobs in a
teacher do not even come close as you
know very simple this is this is this is
this is very very simple it's very
simple in front of you guys and like I
said before difference between us the
animals and the angels if you follow
your desires
what's a difference between you and that
cat or animal he's like even ghost
toilet like you and his followers
desires there's no difference if you
want to be better than the Angels Allah
has given you a free will
you have the angels have to do as
they're told you have the free will to
abstain from it that's the problem since
hope you guys have enjoyed this video
insha'Allah
once again insha'Allah want to say thank
you to the Muslim box company they are
blessed em shake out their products as
well
inshallah the merge documentary we are
working very hard on it with it hard on
it inshallah it's gonna come out at the
end soon inshallah na